the first game that was postponed
because of the pandemic and actually
it's better now because it's a bigger
deal three unbeaten teams left two of
them square off this weekend something's
got to give between this great defense
and this incredible offense that
tennessee has quietly put together the
titans reportedly will not be losing
draft picks for whatever covet 19
violations they committed so the wobble
continues for the nfl week and a half
ago it was and they were putting the
word out they were putting the word out
that they were going to hammer the
titans with potentially historic
punishment then last week the word
starts getting out the nfl is not going
to do anything at all well now it kind
of starts to swing back a little bit
they're going to get some sort of a
parking ticket apparently but not
anything close to what people thought
they were going to get for unauthorized
practice sessions whatever covet 19
violations contributed to an outbreak in
the building and there's still some
lingering questions about what they knew
and when they knew it about the outbreak
they were experiencing when they went to
minnesota three weeks ago just a day
before all hell broke loose so some sort
of
quiet punishment for the tennessee
titans but nothing like what the nfl
was expecting to do and they need to do
something because last week when it
became clear that they weren't going to
do
what people thought other teams are like
well what's the what's the you know
other than your own disruption you don't
have that deterrence that the nfl wanted
to bake into this so i think they need
to do something to let other teams know
that there will be serious punishments
beyond your own inconvenience and
possibly not being ready to play games
because you didn't practice and
everything that goes along with that
over and above that there will be
punishment from the nfl if you don't do
what you're supposed to do
and mike it all mess meshes with what i
heard from roger goodell we on that
conference call recently and and he said
this is more about protocols and getting
things right and making sure teams
comply as opposed to any kind of
punishment and he felt good about them
cooperating with what was going on and
and so here we sit with with likely a
slap on the wrist after we heard that it
was going to be a very heavy punishment
get hammered but mike you think when
they let the word out about the getting
hammered that that's when they wanted
other teams to be scared and make sure
they were following those protocols now
maybe they don't now but don't you think
that was some of that to make sure that
other teams comply that maybe weren't
complying
if they did it was hollywood quality
acting because they were telling
multiple teams this is what is going on
to the point where when i started to
hear the other side of it i went back to
some of the people who told me what they
had heard from the league and i said hey
i'm starting to hear they're not gonna
do anything at all and they were mad
they're like this is baloney they got on
the phone and they told us this is what
they're going to do and they were
getting that word out this is what
they're going to do you know it's just
part of the
there's a political reality to any
organization don't just drop the hammer
on somebody when you get 32 different
teams you get the word out what you're
thinking about doing and may i don't
know i just think that if it was
deliberate aimed at scaring people
straight
it's it's not smart to do it that way
because if you ultimately don't do it
it's the it's the
the hollow threat that no one else is
going to take seriously but i do like
this approach
differently than uh the bounty scandal
when there was a cultural issue in the
nfl and the nfl identified one team of
many that was violating the anti-bounty
policies and hammered the saints and
basically used that to scare everyone
else into stopping
the better thing to do is tell everyone
look you got to stop this and next time
whoever does it is going to pay but
we're going to give everyone a pass for
now because we assume everybody's had
mass irregularities he'll just watch the
sidelines during a game so you know and
they're bigger
i think their bigger challenges hold it
all together they're so focused on
holding everything together that they
haven't really gotten to the punishment
phase with the titans and help it's been
two weeks since john gruden after being
found a hundred thousand dollars his
mask clearly not on and the nfl said
they were going to do something to him
about it they haven't been able to get
to that because he's still been dealing
with the titans and there's all these
other brush fires that they're putting
out one after another it's like every
day there's another team that's got some
issue a lot of times the fall is
positive but i just think their main
objective at this point they realize
everyone's got an incentive
to try to keep this out of their
building and to try to avoid an outbreak
and i think the nfl's incentive is help
everyone do it so they ultimately don't
lose
games the most egregious thing to me
mike though was the off-site practices
because they had specifically been told
by the nfl do not do this do not have
off-site practices and whether coaches
were involved or not i guarantee you the
coaches knew they were having off-site
workouts there's no way they didn't know
that these off-site workouts were going
on and to put a kibosh on that and say
we aren't going to do this the nfl has
told us not to do this so that to me is
is the the biggest thing that they did
you know we don't know everything that
went on in that building of course
whether they were fully complying with
the mass we know they weren't fully
complying and things like that but to
specifically be told don't go practice
off-site and then to go do it that to me
was the biggest thing they should be
penalized for
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports